por el bien del país con esa fórmula el
vicepresidente de guatemala pidió al
presidente que renuncien de juntos
asimismo admitió que no tiene una buena
relación con el mandatario y que no
comparte muchos asuntos que forman parte
de la agenda del estado quiero dejar muy
claro el planteamiento que le he hecho
al presidente por el bien del país que
presentemos ambos nuestra renuncia al
cargo el de presidente y yo de
vicepresidente de la república pero que
lo hagamos juntos la declaración de
castellón se desató luego de una oleada
de protestas en redes sociales en contra
de la aprobación del presupuesto del
estado 2021 avalado por el presidente
alejandro giammatei el pasado miércoles
este presupuesto es criticado por sumar
endeudamiento y por haber sido aprobado
sin discusión en el congreso
kast yo también ha solicitado al
presidente que evalúen juntos las
carteras del estado para remover a
varios ministros minutos antes de que
castillo planteara la propuesta de
disolución de la actual
llama 'the y había expresado su
intención de mantener vigente al
presupuesto aprobado debo aclarar que me
sentaré con todos los que sea necesario
para explicarles paso a paso el
presupuesto 2021 y aclarar dudas porque
jamás en la historia se ha presentado un
presupuesto menor al año anterior a
diversos grupos de la sociedad han
convocado a una manifestación este
sábado para mostrar su descontento a la
aprobación opaca de un presupuesto que
según especialistas prioriza la
asignación a infraestructuras pero
descuida a la población y sus
necesidades